the program itself
so as you know uh the surveillance
of stars cove two and specifically
variance of concern is an ongoing effort
that is critical
to the successful strategy that will
help overcome
challenges related to vaccination
related to other factors that contribute
to the emergence
of novel variants and to the ways that
these could be addressed with prevention
treatment
vaccination and other types of measures
so what we wanted to do in this program
is to introduce all of the participants
to
data repositories how to effectively use
them
including repositories like ncbi virus
and gis aid
where millions of sequences from around
the world
have been shared just in the context of
this pandemic but
importantly the rate of submission is
continuing to grow
and we'll talk a lot more about what
kind of data
and how to find the right kind of data
relevant kind of data to structure a
bioinformatics project
but we also will talk about some of the
analysis tools
that help us translate this data to
information that is relevant
so what kind of methods are we going to
be talking about we're going to be
talking about sequence alignment
gene expression studies how to analyze
the immune responses
to the infection how to organize our
data
in a phylogenetic treaty and use
molecular clock to kind of
understand the timing that helps us
establish
some difference between sequences or
groups of sequences
we'll talk about structural biology how
we can map these variants
onto the structure of the critical
proteins like the spike protein
and we'll talk about variant calling how
in all of this
data that comes from different sources
with different methods of sequencing
different depth of sequencing
how can we extract confidently that
specific variants
that are of interest and then we'll also
talk about how
to utilize these methods using the t
bioinfo platform which allows for
a seamless end-to-end processing
visualization
and analysis of sequencing data but also
how to use
r to then prepare reporting on the
identified variation and how to look at
those reports
following some examples of industry
standards that are being used
by teams around the world that are
continuously engaged in this
effort of monitoring the emerging
variants and the
development of variation in this virus
so here you can see on ncbi how
ncbi right before the pandemic or maybe
even during the pandemic
has updated this interface for ncbi
virus makes it very
easy to find specific sequences so we'll
actually go and do some hands-on
exercises
to find sequences from different animals
from
different time points compared different
source cove
one and two variants or sorry uh
genomes and how to then track the
progression in time
so it's a very useful interface and then
down here below
you can also see some recent statistics
on the number of
uh sequences genomic sequences that have
been submitted for
the novel coronavirus so really a huge
repository that all of us have access to
and we'll talk about how to gain access
how to know how to filter and find
specific types of data that you need
and then how to also structure your
bioinformatics research question
using this information and perhaps talk
to you about the
questions you might already have and
think through how can we
organize that and translate that into a
technical sequence
of steps that you can follow to actually
get reliable
and meaningful results from this
information so the important
outcomes for this program is to study
trends behind the emergence of source
code two variants
we'll talk about the emergence of the
virus the infection itself where did it
come from and how do we know
where it could have come from we're not
going to be addressing
any kind of speculation about where we
can know
the specific location of the emergence
of the time of the emergence but we'll
talk about
how do we use genomic data to know
the source to identify a common ancestor
we'll talk about genomic surveillance
what does genomic surveillance mean
how is data collected different types of
sequencing technologies different types
of
bioinformatics analysis methods we'll
talk about downstream analysis of
genomic data so how we can
use information from genomic data sets
to
understand phylogeny or evolution how do
we
track origin and how do we report
accurately
the type of analysis that we've done
we'll talk about
creating a report on genomic genomic
sequencing data using cloud processing
in a custom r script so i'll talk a
little bit more about that in a few
minutes
and we'll talk about future directions
for these large-scale vaccination
efforts and variant of concern
monitoring so where is it going
what are some of the factors that we
should be mindful of
as we track the emergence of existing
and novel variants of concern and some
ideas about
classification why it's an important
effort so
to start it off i want to briefly
kind of go back to where we came from
how did we actually get to this point of
knowing that there are many different
variants and many different variants of
concern and what's the difference
so as you can see here probably most of
you are already familiar with this type
of visualization this is
a phylogenetic tree that shows us how
over time on the x-axis we see emergence
of different groups
that right here are already colored by
their
phylogenetic taxonomy so these are the
different
names of strains and you can see down at
the bottom
the proportion of these strains in the
worldwide population so
we originally have been introduced
already to this idea that
genomic data can provide us with a
time series type of analysis
that demonstrates how variants of
concern
have changed in proportion of infected
cases now
there are many issues around this
specific type of reporting
from a data perspective of course
there's the sampling rate
there are the specific methods that have
been used to determine
association with different taxonomic
units and so that is why essentially it
is very critical
to look at this data and look at this
type of reporting
with in-depth understanding so for
example here you can see
how the number of types of clades
that have been reported is growing
over the course of this pandemic from
three
then to five to then eight and then to
ten and so
that number will continue to grow
and the specific proportions here are
important as well so you can see that
some
are completely going to disappear over
time some are going to emerge and become
completely new
and so over time the dynamic of
emergence and reappearance of some of
these variants is called
phylodynamics so this is a phylodynamic
vu
of this source cov2 phylogeny so we
conduct a phylogenetic analysis we look
at
genomic variation and then we include
the component of time
so really the objective of this analysis
is to try to identify
the factors that drive this variation as
it emerges
as it emerges across time and so because
of the availability of
data and because of this universal
approach to taxonomic classification we
now
can look specifically at each type of
variant
to understand how they individually
develop over time so what you can see
here are the specific variants
that have a proportion by country
and you can see that most of the
countries are going up but
not in a linear and not in a uniform
fashion
so you can see that there's a lot of
variation by region and country
you can also see the specific mutations
that define
a particular clade or a strain so here
you can see
specific variants of concern down at the
bottom the
famous ones like the uk south africa and
brazil
and you can also see how these mutations
are mapped onto 3d structures so
all of this information is widely
accessible
and i think what is the major point
is for us to be able to track
the data as it emerges and to be able to
apply these meaningful
analytical techniques to gain a better
understanding of the biology behind the
individual
variants to understand the complexity of
this taxonomic classification
and then to be able to sample new data
that is coming out
and find relevant information in this
new data that we can make decisions
based on so what's important is
obviously to also
think about these new developments and
all of us have been hearing
not so long ago this novel delta variant
emerged in england or sorry in india not
so far ago
and not so long ago and this new delta
variant the b1617.2
uh how it has been growing tremendously
i think by june has accounted for about
70 percent of
all the new infections so it's a major
concern
especially because the vaccine
effectiveness
against this new delta variant seems to
be
incomplete so it does not offer a
hundred percent
or even a 95 as originally was tested
for pfizer for astrazeneca even lower 60
effective remember that fda approval is
after typically 70
so really major challenges to these
standard approaches to one type of a
vaccine
and needing the additional effort to
really understand
the phylodynamics how is this strain
going to continue to evolve
are there new strains that are going to
be added on to this b16172
so importantly if we go back to this
slide
you can see that major mutations
non-synonymous as well as synonymous are
not
unique for each string in fact all of
these defining mutations
overlap in many cases between the
individual
strains that are reported for example
you can even see in the naming b117
one three five one right so the b was
one of the
original clays that separated from the a
clade
and so as we continue accumulation of
novel mutations means that this is not a
completely new strain it's really
additional numbers of mutations that we
need to understand
their impact collectively on
this effort to address the problem with
vaccines
not only that important new changes to
this
new strain is that it affects much
more significantly the younger
population which was not true for their
original strain
it also tends to be a problem for people
that have
one or even two shots of the vaccine and
it is spreading much faster so there are
additional
challenges that we should be
anticipating as this process continues
but to really
study this problem or this challenge in
detail
i think we need to go back understand
the biology
behind source code ii the infection
itself
the rate of transmission as well as the
evolutionary changes that are starting
to appear in the genome
and to understand this biology at the
level
of reporting so that we can accurately
look and sample at data
and we can start asking questions about
these individual mutations
so here what you can see is the
organization of the genome
the genome is about 30 000 nucleotides
long it has a number of different
proteins that are encoded in genes so
some genes are protein coding genes and
some are non-protein coding
genes and what we want to do is find an
approach that allows us to identify some
significant mutations that you can see
here
higher on the y-axis and start asking
questions about
the position on the genome their rate
of change and how can we associate this
with phenotype that ultimately could be
defined in multiple several ways
one way that we could characterize these
mutations is to start looking at how
these mutations are present on the 3d
structure
and so by understanding the 3d structure
and how it functions how it works
we can start asking questions about
whether we
understand what the potential impact of
this mutation is
on the interaction between the viral
host the viral and host protein
interaction
another way that we can study this is to
look at
experiments that show how genome
replication rate changes because of
these mutations so here's an example
from that kind of a study
you can essentially infect cells
and track the number of genomes and some
interpretation about that rate
and change is also important we can also
look at the type of change so we can ask
the question whether
a specific nucleotide changing to a
different nucleotide
it is also going to result in a change
in the amino acid and what kind of a
change in the amino acid will it
be how evolutionary likely
is that change based on blossom scores
or how the physical chemical
properties of that specific change could
affect the interaction again with the
different proteins
so many different types of questions
that we can ask
but ultimately we need data and so to be
able to ask these kinds of questions i
think we can rely
first of all on scientific literature
that has been peer reviewed
and as you know there have been
thousands and thousands of publications
that have been coming out at a very
rapid speed to tell us about novel
insights about the virus itself
individual proteins
as well as the interaction with the host
so what we want to focus on
in this program is to take you through
a number of curated data sets and
associated publications
that will help us set a context for the
source code to emerging variants of
concern as well as some of the aspects
of vaccine design drug design
immune responses and other factors that
we think are
critical for understanding of how this
genomic data could be
useful and how it could offer new
insights
and important insights on the ground
about this effort that is ongoing
so one thing that we will talk about in
detail
is the organization of this spike
protein how the protein is organized
what do we know about the protein and
its function how can we
ultimately look at the interaction
between
the viral proteins and the host proteins
and
ask questions about specific regions or
functional domains
that are important in this process of
interaction in addition to that we will
then
take a look at the connection between
genomic data
as you can see here at the bottom and
the protein data that is available
to start asking the question about rate
of change
or mutation frequency that is observed
by sampling specific
groups of genomic sequences available in
the public domain
we will also talk about what are some of
the potential
selective pressures that could explain
the emergence of specific mutations that
we observe so we will talk about
how antiviral drugs have been applied
how host immune responses might be
responsible for
specific changes and then try to link
that with
genomic information that we have about
specific types of
genomic uh genomes from the sonoroscope
to
databases so that we can link those
processes together and
ultimately ask the question of
specific mutation patterns
that could explain what we observe
in the drug treatment in the vaccine
treatment
in the host immunity patterns that are
already being studied
and so this information is also
important because
many early stage studies about the
immune responses that are
typical that are maybe abnormal
in acute infection or typical for
mild or asymptomatic infection can
really start putting together
the pieces of the puzzle for us to be
more informed
about how the interaction with the virus
happens
in the course of the disease how it
affects outcomes
and then start using that information to
understand the specifics of these
novel variants of concern so what's
good about this is that there are many
publications already and these
publications come
with a lot of data sets that we can all
access
so ultimately we will not only look at
the reported
clinical genomic information that is
sampled from populations at different
time points but we will also take a look
at the more research data that is
available for cell ion experiments
animal experiments as well as
experiments done on
human cell lines and from downstream
patient studies so
we will talk about all of these aspects
in the program and try to link the
information that is being reported in
the specific types of
publications that also goes beyond
these individual point mutations but
also talks about
deletions and also multi-nucleotide
changes that are observed in these
sequences which is an important part of
information that is present in this
genomic data
but is not as often being being being
reported or
spoken about as prominently as we hear
about
these point mutations that might have a
consequence on
the protein structure so we will try to
look at the clinical side
and public health side but also we will
deep deeper
into the research side and try to
understand
what other types of variations and data
are present
and how should we utilize this
information
in the context of the genomic data that
everyone else is speaking about
so the program itself is a part of our
standard onyx logic bioinformatics
training program called bioinformatics
for infectious diseases
but it has a much more specific and
in-depth focus on the source code 2
genomic data transcriptomic data
structural data and specifically with
this additional focus on the variance of
concern
and so we will introduce you to some of
the important
efforts that are being done throughout
this country in the us as well as
worldwide where there are specific
objectives to
leverage some of the genomic
surveillance for
informed decisions that could be done
by the u.s public and academic
institutions to really
address this challenge of novel variants
and to practice for the hands-on portion
of the program we will also talk about
specific analytical tools that will
include
consensus level analysis of variance
this is something that you can use in
your
research work this is something that you
can use to design
independent bioinformatics project as a
citizen science or as a
scientist or as a student and also
something that you could leverage
to gain skills in all of these
aspects of analysis so what are the
specific
types of activities that we will do
we'll perform
consensus level analysis of variance so
if you can imagine
a sequencing data set with
specific depth how do you identify the
consensus of where
those variants are present in all of the
reads or in the
larger proportion of the reads how to
detect
novel and prevalent variants which means
that we will look for specific positions
that have been reported
and find whether those are present or
not and at which
which proportion in given samples we
will also look at sub consensus
and low frequency variance which is an
important part
that we already talked about that
ultimately the emergence
of these prevalent variants starts with
a presence of low frequency mutations
that
eventually gain prominence and so that
really demonstrates the evolutionary
uh kind of struggle that happens between
the host
and the virus where the progeny of the
or
original viral strain divides up into
these subclades and then
some clade becomes more efficient at
overcoming the immune pressures
ultimately becoming the dominant strain
so we'll look at that sub-consensus
analysis and how to detect low frequency
variants
we'll also talk about low quality
samples one of the major things that
is ongoing right now is sampling data
from
wastewater and taking data sets that
might not have
high level of accuracy like luminous
sequencing but instead oxford nanopore
sequencing
and how can we leverage that same data
using some quality control measures
to identify variants of concern and then
we'll also
look at population scale tracking the
spread and emergence of variance
in densely populated areas so we'll take
some curated
project examples for that now as we go
through these
topics we will also touch on some of the
basic concepts that you have to know
to be able to participate in such
studies and that includes an
understanding of different types of
sequencing techniques
understanding of data types and data
file formats we will also talk about
the specific details that allow us to
leverage quality control in a meaningful
way
we will talk about the process of
sequence alignment based on different
types of data like
fast queue or fasta files we'll
study specific types of protocols that
will give us a better sense
of how data is generated and what types
of steps
are needed to use that data in a
meaningful way
and then we'll actually go through some
examples
of wastewater sequencing and other types
of sequencing and
what are the sources and the outcomes
for each type of study
and we will introduce you to some
user-friendly tools
that are available on the tbi info
platform to perform
multiple types of bioinformatic
pipelines that
cover the phylogenetic analysis variant
calling gene expression and structural
biology aspects of bioinformatics
workflow that are important to know in
the context of such studies
so ultimately what that means is
building pipelines from
logical steps understanding how these
logical steps tied together
and knowing what are the inputs and
outputs so that your analysis
is meaningful and reproducible
for example one of the exam one of the
useful
kind of views i think that has been on
everyone's mind is
how do we identify the origins of source
code ii
in terms of zonotic transmission and so
here we will turn to some of the
published
data sets and published papers that help
us use
the logic behind viral emergence and
biology
and bioinformatics methods that allow us
to study
similarity between sequences to ask
questions about
the potential or the likelihood of
zoonotic transmission between different
known species
on the other hand we will also look at
some of the well studied and known
examples
that show specific changes at the
nucleotide level and the amino acid
level
to really understand how we can come to
conclusions
that have been reported in the public
domain
and this mutation the 614 gene mutation
that was well studied and i think well
understood
has really become a great example of how
we can
link the phylogenetic information
the specific variant calling information
that we can focus on
and the biological understanding of its
structural
and uh physical chemical interaction
properties
that we can translate into a meaningful
insight
about an identified mutation now this is
a single
mutation that we were talking about but
ultimately when you look at data
you are present with a lot of
information for
each individual sample that contains
many numbers of mutations
that are typically present in a given
sample and so one of the challenges that
you will come across is how do i
interpret this in a meaningful way
knowing that
many of these mutations are either
reported
in literature and databases or not
reported
they could lead to structural variation
or not lead to structural variation
and then how do we look at them together
complementary to each other or
detrimental to each other
to ultimately link it to a specific
phenotypic change and so that's why all
of these steps these analytical steps
are very important so we'll
take some time to study pre-processing
and quality assurance
aspects of sequencing data and then we
will turn to generating a report a
meaningful report
based on what is standard or kind of
uh something that people use in the
industry and the research
in general so this is an example of a
report from cosmos ied
a commercial report that one might get
from sending your data to a sequencing
lab
and we will perform the exact same
analysis
using tools in r so this is the report
that we will
generate using our scripts that take
process data from a pipeline and turn it
into a visual
and statistically significant report
that we can share with our collaborators
and partners
and so to produce this report we will
actually go through the code and learn
about some
useful packages that are typically used
for visualizing and performing
statistical analysis of data
including ggplot2 and some
other libraries for managing and working
with your
raw data including looking at the
specific positions
that are associated with a variant like
the us
or the uk sorry the uk south african
brazil
variants including the delta and the
delta plus variants
and so this is going to be the
culmination of this program where you
will be able to
sample some raw sequencing data load it
into the pipeline
produce the output of the pipeline and
then analyze that
whole pipeline output to generate a
report that you can share in a pdf
or a full report that you both
understand the statistical prevalence
the variance of concern but also their
biological relevance
now uh let's briefly go over some of the
program resources
so that everyone is